[Applause]
[Music]
my Lords pray be seated
to attend her majesty immediately in the
House of Peers
[Music]
my Lords and members of the House of
Commons my government's priority has
always been to secure the United
Kingdom's departure from the European
Union on the 31st of October my
government intends to work towards a new
partnership with the European Union
based on free trade and friendly
cooperation my ministers will work to
implement new regimes for Fisheries
agriculture and trade seizing the
opportunities that arise from leaving
the European Union an immigration bill
ending free movement will lay the
foundation for a fair modern and global
immigration system my government remains
committed to ensuring that resident
European citizens who have built their
lives in and contributed so much to the
United Kingdom have the right to remain
the bill will include measures that
reinforce this commitment steps will be
taken to provide certainty stability and
new opportunities for the financial
services and legal sectors my
government's new economic plan will be
underpinned by a responsible fiscal
strategy investing in economic growth
while maintaining the sustainability of
the public finances measures will be
brought forward to support and
strengthen the National Health Service
its workforce and resources enabling it
to deliver the highest quality care new
laws will be taken forward to help
implement the national health services
long-term plan in England and to
establish an independent body to
investigate serious health care
incidents my government will bring
forward proposals to reform adult social
care in England to ensure dignity
in age my ministers will continue work
to reform the Mental Health Act to
improve respect for and care of their is
receiving treatment my government is
committed to addressing violent crime
and to strengthening public confidence
in the criminal justice system new
sentencing laws will see that the most
serious offenders spend longer in
custody to reflect better the severity
of their crimes measures will be
introduced to improve the justice
system's response to foreign national
offenders my government will work to
improve safety and security in prisons
and to strengthen the rehabilitation of
offenders proposals will be brought
forward to ensure that victims receive
the support they need and the justice
they deserve those will be introduced to
ensure that the parole system recognizes
the paint victims and their families
caused by offenders refusing to disclose
information relating to their crimes a
new duty will be placed on public sector
bodies ensuring they work together to
address serious violence police officers
will be provided with the protections
they need to keep the population safe
they will also be awarded the power to
arrest individuals who are wanted by
trusted international partners my
government will bring forward measures
to protect individuals families and
their homes legislation will transform
the approach of the justice system and
other agencies to victims of domestic
abuse and minimize the impact of divorce
particularly on children my ministers
will continue to develop proposals to
improve Internet safety and will bring
forward laws
implement new building safety standards
my ministers will ensure that all young
people have access to an excellent
education unlocking their full potential
and preparing them for the world of work
my government will take steps to make
work fairer introducing measures that
will support those working hard to help
people plan for the future measures will
be brought forward to provide simpler
oversight of pension savings to protect
people savings for later life new laws
will provide greater powers to tackle
irresponsible management of private
pension schemes to ensure that the
benefits of a prospering economy reach
every corner of the United Kingdom my
ministers will bring forward a national
infrastructure strategy this will set
out a long-term vision to improve the
nation's digital transport and energy
infrastructure new legislation will help
accelerate the delivery of fast reliable
and secure broadband networks to
millions of homes an aviation bill will
provide for the effective and efficient
management of the United Kingdom's
airspace proposals on railway reform
will be brought forward a white paper
will publish be published to set out my
government's ambitions for unleashing
regional potential in England and to
enable decisions that affect local
people to be made at a local level my
government is committed to establishing
the United Kingdom as a world leader in
scientific capability and space
technology increased investment in
science will be complemented by the
development of a new funding agency a
more open visa system and an ambitious
space strategy by ministers remain
committed to protecting and improving
the environment for future generations
for the first time environmental
principles will be enshrined in law
measures will be introduced to improve
air and water quality tackle plastic
pollution and restore habitats so plants
and wildlife can thrive legislation will
also create new legally binding
environmental improvement targets a new
world leading independent regulator will
be established in statute to scrutinize
environmental policy and law investigate
complaints and take enforcement action
proposals will also be brought forward
to promote and protect the welfare of
animals including banning imports from
trophy hunting the integrity and
prosperity of the Union that binds the
four nations of the United Kingdom is of
the utmost importance to my government
my ministers will bring forward measures
to support citizens across all the
nations of the United Kingdom my
government remains committed to working
with all parties in Northern Ireland to
support the return of devolved
government and to address the legacy of
the past my government will take steps
to protect the integrity of democracy
and the electoral system in the United
Kingdom my government will continue to
invest in our gallant Armed Forces my
ministers were honor the Armed Forces
covenant and the NATO commitment to
spend at least two percent of national
income on defense as the United Kingdom
leaves the European Union my government
will ensure that it continues to play a
lead
in global affairs defending its
interests and promoting its values my
government will be at the forefront of
efforts to solve the most complex
international security issues it will
champion global free trade and work
alongside international partners to
solve the most pressing global
challenges it will prioritize tackling
climate change and ensuring that all
girls have access to 12 years of quality
education members of the House of
Commons estimates for the public
services will be laid before you my
Lords and members of the House of
Commons other measures will be laid
before you I pray that the blessing of
Almighty God may rest upon your counsels